é botar todos portanto eu vou pedir
desculpa mas vou falar em português
porque acima de tudo acho que esta
conferência oeste encontra o encontro de
emoções e sentimentos que eu consigo
expressar melhor dos meus sentimentos e
as minhas emoções em português
queria agradecer ao manuel facto de ter
convidado é criar de ser o melhor fugido
para quem ter convidado é um prazer
estar aqui falar essas coisas sobre a
sempre é só que eu vou descansar uma
coisa eu estou indo isto me assustava
tanto que nem eu não sabia a mínima
idéia do que quer e sei o que eu queria
dizer mas não sabia como quer dizer esta
é uma conferência tão transversal e sai
tão fora das minhas áreas e das
conferências que eu costumo dizer
realmente estava assustada mas diz manhã
gloriosa até a última palestra é eu noto
que nós tanto todas as palestras têm
imensa coisa em comum portanto agora
estou muito mais à vontade porque
realmente mesmo sendo áreas tão
diferentes aqui uma transmissão de dados
tão grande mas com coisas muito comuns
aliás sou muito surda também deve dizer
isso é dura exatamente que o triste
porque nós devemos ser absurdos que
seria só contaram eu vou falar muito
depressa no fla não tem nada em termos
de eficiência conceitos científicos
poucos vou dar algumas idéias de que o
que nós fizemos em alguns dos nossos
sucessos portanto não vou falar dos
insucessos já ouviu falar do sucesso
- realmente temos que ser muito surdos
hoje em dia e cada vez mais é eu não sei
se sabe mas chegaram em ônibus a adesão
de 2008 o então projeto do european
business council
portanto são dez maiores bolsas dadas
pela comissão europeia na área das
engenharias e e ciências ciências
físicas e não só ganhe essa vossa como
fiquei em primeiro lugar em termos
europeus o prêmio esso lento da
universidade até portugal é quando
estava a acreditar mesmo projeto fui
saber informações no conteúdo nacional
do contágio em contacto país em portugal
as coisas sobre o orçamento e não sabia
como eu queria fazer e resposta que me
deram foi assim
pode fazer o orçamento como está a
pensar fazer mas devo dizer que estes
projectos e estes grandes são para a
nata da nata européia
bom eu vi e ouvi
portanto o trabalho no programa ciência
e tecnologia na caparica e houve
entraves e pontes devem almoçar e viu
que uma sacola tem notória que é
perguntar tempo e acreditar num projecto
destes
depois é que não vai dar nada no
realmente ainda bem que fui surda porque
não só ganhei como fiquei em primeiro
lugar fantástico
isso também para vos dizer que realmente
tem que ser em volta exata que temos que
ser soltos e temos que cima de tudo
acreditar em nós próprios
portanto acho que se nós acreditamos
naquilo que fazemos e tivemos muita
convicção é que conseguimos lá chegar é
justo dizer aliás nos alunos e e no
laboratório nós tanto aliás nós fazemos
coisas caminharam em algumas áreas me
acho que os americanos e um japonês
é portanto impossível não existe nós
conseguimos sempre fazia tanto não há
impossíveis
bom é o tema da minha palestra viajar e
natureza tecnológica aliás nem fui eu
que escolhi no já não tem muito a ver
com a que com a introdução que foi
ferramenta o grupo de trabalho começou
no fotovoltaico axé luxo mas eu venho te
falar uma coisa completamente diferente
tanto em bangu solar de água da empresa
portanto e só para nos dar uma ideia é
um grupo portanto um trabalho e pelo
menos nas áreas onde nós trabalhamos
portanto não há trabalho individuais que
têm um trabalho de equipa e é uma equipa
muito motivada e equipa tem também uma
particularidade
tanto que além de termos como podem ver
pela imagem que já não está completa
porque é difícil reuniram cerca de 30
pessoas no mesmo dia no mesmo
laboratório porque 95 todos uns por um
lado outros produtos
portanto é uma equipa que tem várias
nacionalidades que fechou em ter e
também vários background portanto tem na
equipa físicos electrotécnicos médicos é
engenheiro químico 71 cedo pessoas que
conseguem ter nós trabalhamos fortemente
nas áreas da investigação aplicada mas é
talvez dessa mistura de saber x100
portanto não só o nível de utilização
das mesmas terrível de empresas
eu penso que desta mistura de diferentes
com 7 por exemplo digamos todos presos
de comando mas com olhos diferentes e é
exatamente de ser partilha muito
diferente que todos têm sobre a mesma
coisa sobre um bloco mesmo objeto que
podemos inovar
eu acho que é este pelo menos um dos
sucessos do nosso trabalho
tentei o meu muito obrigada e suas
mazelas várias áreas do norte
portanto é evidente que não vamos nem
tinha tempo para em tão pouco espaço
falar disto tudo voltou a falar hoje
exatamente da área da eletrônica do
papel foi qualquer coisa que nós fizemos
equipamentos uma revolução está sendo
uma opção em termos mundiais porque é
nossa - em muitas áreas desde
electrónica transparente ainda a
conversão de energia nanotecnologia
sensor shelton aqui alguns exemplos de
alguns protótipos que nós temos
desenvolvido ao longo dos anos
isso é só perguntar me levantou algumas
dessas câmeras olympus nós fazemos essas
coisas tanto quanto trabalhamos com
coisas muito pequeninas e na área de
microeletrônica nanotecnologia é muito
importante portanto ambiente os
laboratórios onde trabalhamos e portanto
qualquer poeta a pressão de sempre durar
na escola e dramática por tantas
condições laboratoriais
quando nós trabalhamos tem kan ter um
controle muito diante vamos falar hoje
exatamente o que o pai período o
transístor de papel
um conceito que eventualmente vocês já
ouviram falar exatamente o tal espírito
de possibilidade que nós temos de poder
usar uma foi normal em cima do papel
como um componente eletrônico é
importante nós enterramos numa folha de
papel celulose e consigo dizer por
exemplo transita de trânsito ea unidade
básica qualquer circuito integrado
nós conseguimos fazer um transístor do
hotel mesmo papel tem uma função ativa
ou seja é um monumento é um material
eletrônico e porque nós somos crianças a
celulose é o material que existem a
mulher se portanto daí o seu baixo custo
é tecnologia do papel em plena campanha
que não esteja aqui o no palco brega
decian pregas da silva da prova
exatamente o que pensavam mas nestas
coisas do que eu que não percebo nada de
papel é é tecnologia é muito antiga
existente nós estamos a desenvolver
qualquer coisa que não é necessário
desenvolver a tecnologia para fazer essa
coisa porque esse tempo já existe
estamos em tarumã crise são
completamente diferentes é um mestre ice
que são convencionais até que estava
a diferença tem uma particularidade
muito importantes que nero na ag na área
do transistor para aplicação em causa é
importantíssima que é o fato do papel
ser um material que tem propriedades o
antes portanto ainda não temos por
exemplo carros elétricos feitiço loss
escolher um dia vamos ter num momento
nada e o material que pode ser reciclado
enquanto isso algumas desvantagens das
ruas nós hoje em dia produzimos uma data
dessas coisas portanto o itec schach é
evidente que essas coisas não são uma
solução deixou um contributo para
pequenas funções e realmente nós somos
uma rede nós que cada um de nós
conseguir fazer uma coisa todos nós
conseguimos fazer muita coisa que tem é
que nós produzimos hoje em dia e
enviamos estas coisas portanto hoje em
dia fala-se muito na reciclagem a
intuição ambiente verde até 60 nas
ferramentas por vezes nós não estamos a
resolver o problema por vezes aquilo que
acontece desde que aconteça em termos
práticos
estamos a enviar nós estamos a
deslocalizar um problema para outras
partes do planeta
bom hoje em dia toda a gente já ouviu
falar nos impactos nos irrita os
notebooks
aliás há vários equipamentos eletrônicos
à venda em que de nós deixarmos de
utilizar os seus livros e utilizarmos o
equipamento informático tem a mesma
função pré de um livro ou até de um
jornal
o que nós fizemos nós fechamos fazer
coisas diferentes geralmente trabalhamos
encontra contra corrente
então pensamos o que nos lembramos de
fazer pensarmos o é da esquerda pra
direita e continuamos somos muito
teimosos continuamos para vencer os
últimos terremotos
continuamos a utilizar o papel só que o
papel tem uma função mesmo eletrônicos
sejam conseguidos eletrônica com o papel
se lavar as ruas de que esse o papel tem
não só noé é simultaneamento suportes do
meu trânsito mas também componente ativo
do transita e textura do trânsito tanto
não vou que entrar em detalhes nas
imagina
fazer uma fotocópia stream e verso é nós
que fazemos é exatamente a mesma coisa e
ramos numa folha de papel e depositamos
ainda os esforços do papel
um dos materiais mil condutores que
tenha te ver com electrónica
transparente os óxidos e também
materiais amigos do ambiente
tanto depositar as suas camadas muito
finas são cerca de lançar umas dezenas
de nada nós depositamos em ambas as
faces do papel
os materiais que compõem o trânsito
tanto precisam transitar em termos
gerais precisa basicamente três tipos de
materiais que mantém os condutores
materiais isolantes e materiais
semicondutores tanto papel era o
material com as chegadas durante o
culturismo enquanto janta unidos em
sinal que eu vou falar mais
tanto basicamente um transístor é um
switch 198 optou está ligado ou
desligado portanto não interessa aqui o
caso e só para verem o transístor de
papel funciona é importante funciona com
o mesmo como transita convencional isto
é que o que aconteceu falar em
eletrônica nós associamos eletrônica
estas coisas
os nossos trânsito são coisas em papel
tão simples como isto é uma coisa me diz
kiko como as camadas de materiais são
tão fininho chão dezenas de nox e a
rugosidade papel é tão elevada nós não
alterará em nada é muito fugir da
superfície do papel ou seja continua
poder escrever sobre o papel
mesmo com os três estão já inscritos
pronto foi noticiado em amã tite mexeu
gosto particularmente deste desta
notícia que saiu no economista tentar
uma secção de tecnologia e o título da
notícia era looks google no pé e pronto
pra mim diz paulo em outras vezes
conseguimos fazer uma memória do papel
mercado imenso importante porque a
imaginação é é quem passará a funcionar
e não podia deixar eu acho que tenha
sido uma palestra da segunda palestra da
manhã tanto gosta gosta imenso desta
deste destino de assassínio em que
realmente nós temos que pensar grande e
espera ser grande se não pensarmos dessa
forma nunca achamos muito obrigada
[Aplausos]